Diese Reise
lässt mich China neu entdecken.
Xifan Yang
führt mich zurück in ihre Kindheit,
ins Leben der Provinz
und ins Herz ihres Grossvaters.
Mao raubte ihm die Jugend.
Doch er hat noch einen Traum:
Er will berühmt werden.
* Er singt auf Chinesisch. *
Ohne seine Enkelin Xifan
hätte ich Opa Peng nie kennengelernt.
Xifan ist meine Brücke
zwischen Ost und West
und zwischen heute und gestern.
Ich bin so, wie ich bin, weil ich
in Deutschland aufgewachsen bin
und auch immer wieder
in China gewesen bin,
weil ich dieses Spannungsfeld
in meinem ganzen Leben erlebt habe.
Um China zu verstehen,
erforscht sie ihre Familiengeschichte
und Grossvaters Jugend
unter Mao Zedong.
Dieser Film ist eine Annäherung
zwischen Enkelin und Grossvater,
zwischen gestern und heute
und zwischen China und mir.
Das ist die Ahnenhalle
der Familie Peng.
Schanghai, das New York Asiens.
Hier stellt China
seinen Reichtum zur Schau.
Hier bin ich
seit vier Jahren zu Hause -
im Schmelztiegel
zwischen Moderne und Tradition.
In der wohl sichersten
und saubersten Stadt ganz Chinas.
Unsere Reise
beginnt an der Julu Road,
wo China
noch fast so aussieht wie damals,
als Xifan
in der tiefen Provinz zur Welt kam.
Mit vier zog sie
zu ihren Eltern nach Deutschland
und ging dort zur Schule -
gut 20 Jahre ist das her.
Jetzt kommt sie zurück nach China.
China hat sich komplett verändert,
genauso wie Xifans Leben,
und langsam bröckeln sogar
die Klischees, sagt sie.
Als ich Kind war,
brachten die meisten Deutschen China
nur mit Reishüten, Hundefleisch
und vielleicht noch Menschenrechts-
verletzungen in Verbindung.
Und damals war auch ganz klar,
wenn mich Leute
auf der Strasse angesprochen haben,
war ich gleich das Einwandererkind.
Inzwischen werde ich - in München
v.a. - auf Englisch angesprochen,
weil sie denken,
ich sei beruflich in Europa
oder ich sei Touristin,
die viel Geld ausgeben möchte.
Ich habe Xifan als Bürokollegin
in Schanghai kennengelernt.
* Sie spricht chinesisch. *
Wie ich berichtet sie aus China.
Oft ist sie hin- und hergerissen
zwischen all den Widersprüchen
in diesem verrückten Land.
Aber auch zwischen den Widersprüchen
von Ost und West.
Bist du Chinesin? Bist du Deutsche?
Wo gehörst du hin?
Darüber habe ich ...
lange nachgedacht.
Ich werde das auch oft gefragt.
Inzwischen glaube ich ...
Für mich spielt die Frage
nicht mehr so eine grosse Rolle.
Xifan nimmt mich mit
auf eine Reise zu ihren Wurzeln.
Im Hochgeschwindigkeitszug fahren wir
von Schanghai nach Pingxiang
in den Südwesten Chinas,
dorthin, wo Xifans Familie herkommt.
Früher dauerte die Fahrt im Nachtzug
einen Tag und eine Nacht,
heute bringt uns Chinas schnellster
Zug in gerade mal 6 Std. hin.
Xifan ist stolz auf die Tüchtigkeit
und den Erfolg der Chinesen,
gleichzeitig macht ihr die brutale
Machtpolitik der Regierung Angst.
Im Schnellzugtempo
pflügt der Fortschritt das Land um.
Über 1'000 km Baustelle ziehen
in wenigen Stunden an uns vorbei.
Und nicht zu übersehen:
der Smog, der den Fortschritt
schon fast wieder erstickt.
Neue Hochäuser,
neue Strassen, neue Einkaufszentren:
Hier entsteht das China der Zukunft.
Bei Sonnenaufgang sehen selbst
Industriestädte romantisch aus.
Das gilt auch
für Xifans Heimatstadt Pingxiang.
1,6 Mio. Menschen leben hier.
Für China schon fast ein Dorf.
Im Zentrum trifft Alt auf Neu:
Es ist ein Tanz
zwischen Tradition und Veränderung.
* Fröhliche chinesische Popmusik *
Weiter draussen am Stadtrand
ist Pingxiang noch so wie früher:
Kohlegruben reihen sich
an Arbeitersiedlungen.
So hat die Stadt
vor 20 Jahren ausgesehen,
als Xifan
hier in den Kindergarten ging.
Doch auch Pingxiang
will heute modern sein.
Grosse Teile wurden neu gebaut.
Chinas Fortschritt hat die hintersten
Ecken der Provinz erreicht.
Immer wieder ist Xifan in den
vergangenen Jahren hierhergekommen,
um die Geschichte des Landes
und die Geschichte ihrer Familie
zu erforschen.
Es hat sich eigentlich
alles verändert.
Als ich hier zur Schule ging ...
In der fünften Klasse ging ich
ein halbes Jahr hier zur Schule.
Man musste noch mit dem Nachtzug
nach Schanghai fahren
oder fliegen.
Es gab hier eigentlich nur alte,
rostige Autos auf den Strassen,
die lange Russfahnen
hinter sich herzogen.
Damals gab es nicht mal
einen McDonald's.
Das einzige westliche Restaurant
war der KFC.
Sonst gab es hier nicht so viel.
Kannst du dir vorstellen,
heute hier zu leben?
Hier leben wahrscheinlich nicht.
Aber meine Mutter
kann sich vorstellen,
nach der Rente hierherzukommen.
Das heisst also, solche Städte
bieten den Jungen auch eine Zukunft?
Ich glaube schon.
Es gibt ja inzwischen
Wirtschaftswachstum auf dem Land.
Viele, die weggegangen sind,
wie meine Tante
oder mein anderer Onkel,
viele aus dieser Generation kommen
zurück und investieren das Geld,
das sie draussen verdient haben.
Xifan führt uns weiter zurück
in ihre Vergangenheit.
In diesem Quartier
verbrachte sie ihre frühe Kindheit.
Während vier Jahren
lebte sie bei ihren Grosseltern,
während ihre Eltern
in Deutschland studierten.
Hier hat sich kaum etwas verändert.
Ihr Grossvater lebt heute noch hier.
Ist jemand da?
* Antwort auf Chinesisch *
Hast du nicht abgeschlossen?
Hallo, Grossvater.
Das ist er: der 83-jährige Opa Peng.
Er hat längst auf seine Lieblings-
enkelin aus Deutschland gewartet.
Er will uns als Erstes
in ein Nudelrestaurant einladen.
Wir gehen zu Fuss gleich um die Ecke.
* Gespräch auf Chinesisch *
Haben Sie auch schon
deutsches Essen gehabt?
Einmal.
Einmal. Ich war da einmal.
Deutschland ist ein schöner Ort,
sauber, gesund.
Und die Leute
sind alle so zivilisiert.
Du warst vor 14 Jahren einmal dort.
Woran erinnerst du dich noch?
Die Autobahnen, die Hitler gebaut
hat, sind noch in gutem Zustand.
Diese Antwort
hätte ich jetzt nicht erwartet.
Doch es wird nicht
das letzte Mal sein,
dass uns der Grossvater überrascht.
Xifan bringt das Gespräch zurück
auf ihre eigene Familie.
Sie will wissen, warum eigentlich
ihre Mutter in Deutschland studierte.
Sie war sehr gut in Chemie.
Sie war die einzige unter all den
Studenten in der ganzen Provinz
mit voller Punktzahl
bei der Maturaprüfung.
Sie hatte 100 Punkte. 100 von 100.
Warst du stolz, als sie dann Anfang
1990 wirklich ins Ausland ging?
Ja, klar war ich damals stolz.
Natürlich.
Das war fast
wie die Krönung zum Kaiser damals.
Was sagst du eigentlich dazu,
dass Mama mit mir
in Deutschland geblieben ist?
Weisst du, wenn Kinder
mit der Schule fertig sind,
müssen sie hinaus
in die Gesellschaft.
Wie die Vögel - wenn die flügge sind
und Wind unter die Flügel bekommen,
muss man sie fliegen lassen.
Sie sollen hinausfliegen
in die weite Welt,
sie sollen frei sein und
überall hinfliegen, wo sie wollen.
Auch Xifans Grossvater
wäre gerne geflogen wie ein Vogel,
als er jung war.
Doch Mao Zedong
stutzte ihm die Flügel.
Seine Freiheit holt er sich wie viele
Chinesen jeden Morgen beim Tai-Chi.
* Motorenlärm *
* Sanfte Musik *
Gerne wäre der junge Peng Fancong
Musiker geworden.
Stattdessen geriet er zusammen
mit seiner ganzen Generation
unter die Räder
von Chinas Geschichte.
Sein Leben wurde
zu einem ständigen Schattenboxen
gegen die Launen
des kommunistischen Machtapparates.
Der junge Journalist
galt als Intellektueller
und wurde bald zum Staatsfeind.
Ganz China wurde erfasst
vom Strudel der Kulturrevolution.
Schon Brillenträger und Lehrer
waren suspekt.
"Landarbeit statt Denkarbeit"
lautete Maos Parole damals.
Universitäten wurden geschlossen,
Zeitungen durften nur noch schreiben,
was der Regierung genehm war.
Grossvater Pengs Freigeist
passte da nicht ins System,
seine Artikel waren zu aufmüpfig.
Die Strafe kostete ihn
20 Jahre seines Lebens:
Er wurde zu Zwangsarbeit verbannt
auf den Berg der 1'000 Drachen.
Heute fahren die Leute freiwillig
auf den Drachenberg.
Er ist eine Touristenattraktion.
Schau, wie schön das jetzt hier ist.
Wie ein Fächer,
wie ein Pfau, der sein Rad schlägt.
Man kann es kaum fassen:
Hier haben Xifans Grossvater
und ihr Onkel
die schlimmsten Jahre ihres Lebens
verbracht.
Zusammen mit
Tausenden anderen Intellektuellen
mussten sie in Landwirtschafts-
kommunen Zwangsarbeit leisten.
Es war ein ständiger Kampf
ums Überleben.
Als wir hier raufmussten, war
die Zeit der schlimmsten drei Jahre.
Es war verdammt schwierig.
An vielen Orten
hatten die Leute nichts zu essen
und hungerten zu Tode.
Im Arbeitslager musste ich
schwere Dinge schleppen.
Ich hatte mal etwas so Schweres auf
meinen Schultern, dass ich umfiel.
Das war nicht weit weg von hier
in Gepuling.
Ich stürzte einen Hang hinunter
und war bewusstlos.
Andere Arbeiter fanden mich
und trugen mich schliesslich
auf einer Bahre zurück.
Es war die Zeit
vom "Grossen Sprung nach vorn",
Maos grösstem Irrtum.
Eigentlich wollte er
die Wirtschaft ankurbeln,
stattdessen verhungerten
über 20 Mio. Menschen.
Xifans Grosseltern konnten
ihre Kinder kaum mehr ernähren.
Der Onkel war damals ein Baby.
Es gab nichts zu essen.
Wir mussten sie
mit Mäusen und Ratten füttern.
Wir gaben ihnen Schlangen
und Spatzen, die wir fingen.
Du kannst dir nicht vorstellen,
wie hart das Leben damals war.
Auch ich habe Mühe,
mir das vorzustellen.
Die Gegend ist heute bekannt für
die Idylle und die frische Bergluft.
Man kommt hierher, um die Stille
und die Natur zu geniessen.
Die tragische Vergangenheit
wirkt wie vertuscht.
Es scheint,
als wäre Grossvater der Einzige,
der sich noch daran erinnert.
Es ist fast ironisch:
Wo damals Leute verhungerten,
schmausen jetzt Touristen
die Spezialitäten der Gegend.
Wo Grossvater einst Mäuse und Ratten
für seine Kinder jagte,
wird heute der beste Räucherschinken
Chinas hergestellt.
In diesem Haus
haben Verwandte von Xifan gelebt.
Es ist das letzte Lehmhaus, das noch
an die düstere Zeit erinnert.
Doch auch das soll verschwinden.
An Maos Verbrechen
soll man sich nicht erinnern.
Natürlich finde ich es unglaublich,
dass meine Familie hier gewohnt hat.
Man kann fast sagen: gehaust hat.
Unter allereinfachsten Bedingungen.
Das kann man sich heute
kaum noch vorstellen.
Für mich ist das sehr bewegend,
weil ...
Ich bin in einer völlig anderen Welt
grossgeworden, im reichen Europa.
Es war für mich etwas ganz
Besonderes, hierherzukommen.
Zu gerne würde ich wissen, was sich
im Kopf des alten Mannes abspielt.
Doch Opa Peng hat gelernt,
die schlimmsten Momente seines Lebens
zu vergessen und zu schweigen.
Die Chinesen
sind ja sehr verschlossen,
was ihre innersten Gefühle angeht.
Ja, also ...
Ich würde das nicht kühl nennen,
es ist einfach ...
Es ist für ihn nichts Besonderes,
das war sein Leben.
Und dieses Leben war geprägt von ihm:
Chinas Staatsgründer Mao Zedong.
Wer sich gegen ihn wehrt,
kämpft noch heute alleine.
Immer noch wird er verehrt,
wie hier am Stadtrand von Pingxiang.
Er hat zig Millionen Menschen
auf dem Gewissen.
Trotzdem heisst es offiziell:
Mao hat 70 % richtig
und 30 % falsch gemacht.
* Er pfeift vor sich hin. *
Grossvater Peng
hat seinen eigenen Weg gefunden,
mit den Irrungen und Wirrungen
von China umzugehen.
Er schreibt gerade ein Lied,
ein neues Lied.
Es heisst "Mein Traum".
Es ist teilweise neu komponiert
und teilweise zusammengefügt
aus einem anderen Lied,
das er früher mal geschrieben hat.
* Er singt auf Chinesisch. *
Der Anfang ist gut.
Hier muss ich noch was ändern.
Die Musik ist sein bester Freund,
glaube ich.
Er hat sich in der Zeit
der Kulturrevolution,
das muss ungefähr 1968
gewesen sein ...
Das war zur Zeit
der schlimmsten Massenversammlungen.
Damals hat man ihn
vor die Menge gezerrt
und er musste Schandhauben tragen.
Und er musste jeden Tag
übelste Beschimpfungen
und auch Schläge
über sich ergehen lassen.
Und auch Schmähungen.
Damals hat er sich
dieses Alter Ego ausgedacht:
Herr Sommerbambus.
Genau.
Und jeden Morgen verwandelt er sich
in diesen Herrn Sommerbambus,
der davon träumt, eines Tages noch
mit seiner Musik berühmt zu werden.
Bis hierhin muss ich nichts mehr
ändern. Der Text passt auch.
* Hupen *
Der Weg zur Berühmtheit ist noch weit
für den Herrn Sommerbambus.
Doch heute
hat er einen grossen Auftritt.
Im Dorf, wo ein Teil von Xifans Sippe
wohnt, erwartet man ihn bereits.
Hier ist Herr Sommerbambus
schon jetzt ein Star.
Nach einer kleinen Stärkung
ist er bereit.
Sein grosser Traum kann beginnen.
* Er singt auf Chinesisch. *
Jetzt hab ich's vergessen.
* Lachen, Stimmengewirr *
Wie geht es ihm im Moment?
Es ist nicht ganz in seinem Sinne
gelaufen. Er hat den Text vergessen.
Heute war es nicht so gut.
Mein Hals kratzt etwas.
Ich bin erkältet.
Aber das letzte Mal war es super.
Da warst du leider nicht dabei.
* Verkehrslärm, Hupen *
Ein langer Tag geht zu Ende.
Wir fahren zurück nach Pingxiang.
Und Herr Sommerbambus verwandelt sich
langsam wieder in Opa Peng.
Die Kohlestadt hustet sich
den Feierabendverkehr aus den Lungen.
Zu Hause in seiner Wohnung
träumt Herr Peng weiter
von einem Leben
als Herr Sommerbambus,
ohne Kulturrevolution und Hungersnot
und von einem Leben
voller Musik und Poesie.
Sein grösster Traum wäre
ein Auftritt in einer Castingshow
im chinesischen Staatsfernsehen.
Ich wünsche ihm,
dass er das noch schafft.
Xifan und ich sind zurück
in der Zukunft, zurück in Schanghai.
Weit weg sind hier die Geschichten
des Herrn Sommerbambus.
Weit weg ist hier Pingxiang
mit seinen Kohleschloten
und dem Drachenberg.
Nach der Reise zu Opa Peng
kann auch ich mir
ein bisschen besser vorstellen,
wie sich Xifans Leben
zwischen zwei Welten anfühlen muss.
Es ist ein Seiltanz, den Xifan
schon ihr ganzes Leben lang kennt.
Man kommt sich so vor, als würde man
aus einem Raumschiff ausgespuckt,
dann ist man hier für ein paar Tage
und dann steigt man wieder
in sein anderes Leben ein
und ist sofort wieder weg.
Und irgendwie denke ich mir:
Nicht nur der Drachenberg,
sondern auch Schanghai
sieht ein bisschen aus
wie ein Pfau, der das Rad schlägt.